the refuse workers in Ankara turn up at
7:00 a.m. every morning whatever the
weather
Guga knockin empties every garbage can
but he also checks each bin bag
carefully looking for books he doesn't
think that books belong in the trash for
years now he and his colleagues have
been bringing them back to the garbage
Depot in Schenck aya
[Music]
Galilei stop as a child I would have
loved to have books but we lived in a
poor district and often there weren't
any school books and sale not that we
could have afforded them now he helps
stop the refuse company's own library
the books first have to be cleansed then
sorted the men have already rescued over
20,000 books from the incinerator all of
us can find books that we like here and
we can educate ourselves further it's
great there's something for everyone in
this library trashy novels and textbooks
and much more in the past 10 years the
number of bookworms has risen from 30 to
42 percent in turkey the library is part
of a growing trend I used to be a road
sweeper
I also found books doing that we used to
get them to children or bring them home
before the library was set up there came
a point when they simply had too many
books so someone came up with the idea
of setting up a library in this
warehouse and the accompany agreed to
help employees can gainfully use time
during breaks or after their shift our
library has now become very famous by
social media we've received many
donations of books from all over the
country Bashan mela should the next idea
is to turn an old garbage truck into a
mobile library for children view of a
knockin and his colleagues are not only
bookworms
but budding musicians too they found
their instruments doing their rounds
Taman there's always such a nice hollow
sound if you beat on the empty cans we
used to drum on them for fun that's how
this began so Ankara doesn't only boast
a garbage library but also a garbage
Orchestra which is even planning to
perform abroad Society has to get used
to the fact that we can also do this
sort of thing
refuse workers aren't only people who
take away the trash and Korea's refuse
workers are showing the world that
garbage can be recycled the good of the
whole community
[Music]